الان الى الاراضي الفيصليه المحتله حيث
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الليله
الماضيه وفجر اليوم عشره فلسطينيين بينهم
اسرى محاضر هنا في مناطق متفرقه بالضفه
الغربيه والقدس المحتله وقال نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني الى قوات الاحتلال اقتحمت
محافظه جنين واعتقلت اربعه فلسطينيين
بينهم الاسير المحرر الشيخ خضر عدنان احد
وقالته حركه الجهاد الاسلامي كما اعتقلت
شابا من مدينه اريحا واخرين من مدينه رام
الله وبنت بيت فجار في بيت لحم وثلاثه
اخرين من ضواحي مدينه القدس المحتله ونقلت
قوات الاحتلال جميع المعتقلين الى مراكز
التوقيف لتحقيق معهم
وقد شيع اهالي مخيم شعفاط شرق القدس
المحتله جثمان شهيد الفتى محمد علي الذي
استشهد برصاص قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
خلال اقتحامها المخيم في الخامس والعشرين
من يناير الماضي وكانت سلطات الاحتلال
سلمت جثمان الفتى محمد لعائلته والشرطت
اتمام مراسم دفنه في غضور ساعتين من موعد
تسليمه